um
how look I I think you and I were
texting early on when the whole uh
departure split of no jumper happened
because I'm real real tight with ad and
I've become cool with t-rell
um over the last year or so
um but I remember just hitting you and
being like this was because I came on
the
show the day after you fired Lush okay
and uh I didn't really understand
what I was walking into I guess to the
fully because I heard you say that on
another show yeah like you really didn't
get one I didn't understand like the
whole gravity of what was happening
right so like
um
yeah it was
[__] uh but you that day was crazy
because I remember
coming out of the room because you have
multiple content rooms and seeing the
dude who uh went on the stream that same
day and like tried to air you out for
the old 2018 [__] like I saw him coming
in really wow yeah that was the same day
so so he was there like I remember
seeing him come in and then I think he
walked over to the stream room and then
me and you took a pic and then I left
but I remember like it was later on that
day or maybe it was it was I think and I
remember just being like oh [__] but you
were going through man bro yeah it was
wild I mean it's cut and I remember
hitting you like hey bro he's like stay
strong but it is weird too because I
feel like that would happen to me now
and I wouldn't give a [__] I mean that
wasn't very long ago right so like at
the end of the day like
I've never really
seen I mean everybody is like yo it's
over for this guy we're not we're not
going on a show he's a clown [__]
he's a you know [__] pedo whatever
the [__] like it was like all this [__]
just getting thrown at the [__] house
at the same time yeah
how was your mental
being and like what was the low for you
just in terms of dealing with that I
mean at that time it was rough because
it was like I just felt like oh
I put years of hard work into like
nurturing these guys as talent and then
they just kind of like turn their back
on me as soon as it's convenient for
them so that was kind of tough to accept
but then at the same time you know just
having the internet in general just
attacking me and even that was like one
thing but dude like it seems so silly
but around that same time there was a
clip of me doing an interview with snico
where we were like having this very
sarcastic conversation about how
disgusting vaginas are like really
anybody who knows me or him would be
able to tell that it was a troll and ass
conversation and that when I was saying
that like penises are so much better
than vaginas you just splash a little
bit of puddle water on it and it's clean
whereas a vagina is an open this is like
a version of like a a joke that I've
basically like been telling like my
whole life thing about how dicks are
better than vaginas whatever but like oh
my God like thousands of porn chicks
just using that clip as an opportunity
to act as if I genuinely hate vaginas
and you know it's just like a lot of
that [__] at all the same time just it
kind of just unloaded on me and yeah it
was really really hard for me at that
time and then I went on the honeymoon
and I kind of like got my mind right
while I was off doing that because all
this is happening right before your
wedding yeah terrible timing very very
stressful for my girl although then we
we go and do the wedding
and it's like
the perfect wedding it was like so good
everything went so smoothly and then it
made me and her feel like well why the
[__] were we so stressed out about the
wedding and the lead up to all this like
on account of all that other [__] you
know did you like uh I mean are you like
a therapy guy I do I had a therapist for
like three years now and I very much
appreciate her and uh she gives me a
very nice space in which I can kind of
air out everything that uh I'm going
through emotionally sometimes it feels
like my therapist and I is like the one
podcast I do a week that nobody ever
gets to hear right you just like working
through [__] you know
um but yeah she definitely helped helped
talk me through all that stuff and at
any point in time
you've already made your money you're
paid you're doing well plug talks
booming at any point in time did you
consider
just being like you know what I don't
need to do this this is worse for me
then it's better for me yeah because
like there was a time where it felt like
they're just watching you it just felt
like there was a time where you just
were like just over this [__] right
because like that whole house phone
thing happened and then that that was
the thing that bothered me is I felt
like oh this is a moment where it's
pretty obvious that
I need the guys who are hosts on the
channel to have my back during this and
like need them to help craft the
narrative that things are just fine here
and instead I felt like I kind of got
the opposite where like a lot of the
hosts on the channel were kind of like
very much actively trying to make the
situation between me and house phone
worse and he gets that now because like
me and house phone have had a lot of
conversations about it and everything
and like you know he we've been talking
all day he's DJing a a show that I'm
doing on Saturday and I don't yeah it
just kind of made me realize like there
was just like a really toxic element
Brewing within no jumper at that time
and you know I don't think that any of
the hosts in particular are like really
bad people I think that they just kind
of had voices in their ears that were
probably concerned with their own
financial situation more than like the
actual long-term careers of these guys
you know so I think that there was just
too many too much [__] going on and
it's crazy because as soon as those guys
left and then we have we still have a
shitload of hosts on the channel and
like a lot of them have been really
growing and stuff and I have hosts who
literally like cannot be in the same
room I cannot have brick baby or whack
100 or you know I can't have whack 100
and crit Mac in the room at the same
time but still like the vibe is way
better than it was before feels like as
much as that [__] kind of hurt going
through those Growing Pains
exercising that drama element out of the
business was like really important
because at a certain point it was just a
lot of people were like coming into no
jumper basically like stirring [__] up
and then going home to their streams and
making tons of content about it and that
just became like the norm every day and
that's why I felt like I needed to take
steps like moving around people on
podcasts and stuff like that because it
was just becoming really really
overwhelming